en Brasil el 31% de la población se
declara evangélica cerca de 70 millones
de personas la mitad apoya el presidente
bolsonaro el candidato de la izquierda
necesita conquistar a este colectivo
para ganar es el objetivo de este acto
electoral en Río de Janeiro nunca
hubo en la historia de Brasil un
presidente que trató la religión y las
iglesias con la democracia con la que yo
cuide este país
Jacqueline es profesora y evangélica en
2018 votó a bolsonaro pero este año va a
dar su preferencia a Lula ella
va a haber mejoras en el área de
Educación va a ayudar a los pobres
principalmente en la periferia de Río de
Janeiro donde yo vivo y va a volver a
generar empleos
una campaña de noticias falsas acusó
válvula de querer encerrar las iglesias
evangélicas en caso de Victoria este
candidato lucha por demostrar lo
contrario sabe que el 54% de las mujeres
rechazan a bolsonaro el voto de las
evangélicas es crucial el voto joven es
otro factor clave en esas elecciones más
de un millón de jóvenes de 16 a 18 años
como ryana acudirán por primera vez a
las urnas
cuando me enteré que podía sacar mi
título electoral le dije a mi padre que
quería hacerlo Aunque yo represente solo
el 1% de la población es muy importante
en Brasil antes de los 18 años el voto
no es obligatorio a una sierra y Ani no
quiso perder la oportunidad de escoger a
bolso
ella tiene su propia opinión política yo
no la influencer ella es de derecha
Hace cuatro años 42 millones de
brasileños se obtuvieron votaron nulo o
en blanco para esta politóloga la
corrupción fue la razón principal ahora
la alta competitividad de este pleito
está haciendo que las personas envuelvan
directamente con las dos candidaturas un
fenómeno que no se ve desde hace mucho
tiempo entonces creo que el fenómeno de
la abstención va a caer este año
esta analista cree que una mayor
participación política puede beneficiar
a la izquierda